a new cbs news battleground tracker poll
could signal good news for democrats in
the state of pennsylvania it shows
democrat john fetterman is leading his
opponent dr mahmet oz by five points
outside the margin of error in the race
for senate over in the governor's
contest democrat josh shapiro has opened
an 11 point lead over trump endorsed
republican doug mastriano of course all
of this could change it's all up to the
voters and on that subject robert costa
went to president biden's hometown of
scranton pa to see what voters are
talking about what voters want bob good
morning
good morning tony pennsylvania is
certainly a hot spot on the political
map many top races up and down the
ballot but the political winds here can
sometimes be hard to read that's why we
wanted to come to pennsylvania talk to
voters directly about the concerns in
their lives and about the candidates
let's bring it back
we can do this with multiple visits by
the president and the former president
hello pennsylvania hello
pennsylvania is once again becoming the
battleground in american politics
cbs news's new survey shows the economy
and inflation remain top concerns eight
in 10 pennsylvania voters say higher
prices have been difficult or worse i
worry all the time about
the economy and health care everybody up
here they're struggling the food is
expensive the gas it's also clear voters
here are paying close attention to
national debates from the fight over
abortion rights to the ongoing probes of
former president donald trump every time
you look around
this commercial zone about this person
or that person pennsylvania's hotly
contested campaigns will be a test of
some of the big questions in american
politics like is a trump endorsement
enough to win a tough race he's going to
work and fight for pennsylvania thank
you dr mehmet oz backed by trump has
been cast as an outsider by democrats
for living for years in new jersey so
anybody can just decide they want to go
and buy a house someplace to run for
office oz's rival democratic lieutenant
governor john fetterman has long been
the front runner who wants
me to be
the 51st vote
he says he's getting better every day
since having a stroke earlier this year
still despite pledging to debate oz ones
fetterman continues to face scrutiny
about how the stroke has affected him
i don't think he's physically able to do
the job i just think they have nobody
else since returning to the trail
fetterman has been busy rallying
democrats especially on abortion rights
and according to the cbs news poll most
democrats say the overturn of roe has
made them more likely to vote this year
women
are the reason
we win
in the race for governor democrat josh
shapiro has also been rallying his
party's voters on abortion rights you
know how high the stakes of this
election are and warning them about
republican doug mastriano an army
veteran who has been backed by trump
he was near the capitol on january 6 and
has repeatedly echoed the former
presidents false claims about the 2020
election i know there's a lot of
problems in our election system in
pennsylvania
amid the political firefight both
fetterman and oz have forcefully
defended themselves
said that fetterman's talk about oz's
residency is a distraction from policy
and a personal attack fetterman has said
that oz's remarks about his health are
out of bounds at the end of the day
voters here tell us they won't be making
their vote based on twitter battles tony
all right bob costa out there with the
people of pennsylvania hearing what they
have to say bob thank you very much
appreciate it